hey everyone it's the great big story
YouTube channel I'm Jillian I'm Dave
welcome to the show this episode is all
about feats of athleticism so first
we're going to go to a marathon that's
one of the hardest in the world
I think glass is crazy but in a very
good way I think it's very smart I think
he knows what he's doing
people think he's a sadist or whatever
like my trail told me where for the
dramatics a tiny bit of a sassy man lads
can draw a true backwoods rebel of
Tennessee created one of the world's
most grueling foot races one that is so
challenging
it leads many to assume it must be an
act of sadism our us aided no no I think
people are obsessed with comfort to the
point that they forget if you don't have
any discomfort in your life how do you
know when you feel good
The Barking marathons is a 100-mile race
comprised of five three-mile weeks if
you have 60 hours to complete it's over
some pretty rugged terrain that's got a
massive amount of climb about sixty six
thousand feet you have just your map and
compass with coals it's wet it's minimal
you're alone the fact that they'll
probably almost certainly fail makes it
more appealing
it started in 85 and we've had 14
finishers are y'all not ready start the
race with a cigarette light which feels
very untraditional for most straight
start yeah we always use a camel because
that's about the best cigarette I think
[Music]
the course is located in frozen head
State Park home to the Brushy Mountain
State Penitentiary a location not chosen
by chance
in 1977 James Earl Ray the man who
killed Martin Luther King jr. made
headlines again when he escaped the
prison in the 54 hours he was free he
only made it eight miles from himself
because the terrain is no joke Jon
Donson
man you have put together a race course
that would really challenge people's
soul I think every runner would like to
do better than James Earl Ray get
further than eight miles although some
of them don't everybody gets a bib
number for each loop
there's paperback books which are kind
of strategically placed so that you can
get them all you have to follow the
course and you pull out the page number
that matches your gift you have to turn
your pages to show that you've done the
course he has a brilliant sense of humor
he's parodying the sport of ultra
marathon running those of us who run
ultras we have a certain egoism that we
think we're pretty good because of what
we can do and so he set out to puncture
that balloon last keeps making it harder
that's the key because he's trying to
put it at the limit of human possibility
[Music]
after they decided that they've had
enough and quit he's like cats on the
bugle both because caps is what you play
for someone who's died in action and
because they they're being tapped out
I think genuinely in his heart he wants
to see people succeed
[Music]
when people actually finish five loops
and you see him at the end he's so
excited and then the F one or more of
them comes in it's an inspiring thing
hard to believe a human can accomplish
that
it's good that some years no one
finished because the Berkeley should win
sometimes
to this next story takes us to the
waters of Hawaii and we're going to meet
a surfer who didn't let a shark attack
scam out of the water I recently told
somebody that getting attacked by a
shark was the greatest thing that's ever
happened to me they're like that's
absurd with that you know why would you
say that I've had incredible
opportunities I've been able to visit
some really cool places and be some
incredible people all these things have
been nurtured from this shark attack I
think it's really made me who I am today
[Music]
my name is Mike coots I live in Island
of Hawaii in Hawaii I'm a surfer
photographer and shark attack survivor
there's some really great surf spots out
here I was 18 years old
surfing here on kawaii with some friends
and it was early in the morning and I
paddled out and thought I was going to
have a surf session like any other day
and it was a lot different I got
attacked by a tiger shark as soon as I
hit it it let go and disappeared back
underwater and I remember passing out
basically as soon as we got to the
hospital and I woke up a day and a half
later an FPT I got my first prosthetic
six months after the shark attack early
on you think you can't do this you think
you can't do that you know there's these
physical limitation the life and I don't
think I could drive a truck with a stick
shift and you learn how to drive a truck
with a stick shift and you're like wow
that was cool and you build up these
little things like day to day to day
after a while it's like bring it on what
what can happen that I can't figure out
how to do I was in college and I
remember class got out like you know
what I'm going to take a longboard I get
the biggest board I could find and just
take my prosthetic in the water and see
what happen
I caught a wave and I was screaming
pretty loud I don't think this is cool
this is amazing and avid dollars like
the best wave had ever thought of my
life from then on I started figure out
okay what's going to break what can I
make that the foot that will help me
surf even better and trying to basically
make the ultimate surfing foot I think
I'm doing it because it's fun but I'm
also it's this learning experience and
it's taking this information and passing
it on to people that want to surf with a
prosthetic
the ocean has taken a lot for me but
what it's given back to me has been
immeasurable
I've lost you know nearly my life to a
shark yet
I really believe sharks are one of the
if not the most important species in our
marine ecosystem at the rate that
they're being killed off they're not
going to be around in 10 15 20 years and
why not use something I could I guess be
set as a negative and turn into a
positive the shark attacks been the
greatest thing that's ever happened next
up we're going to meet Bree who is not
only a Black Hawk mechanic and army but
she's also Alaska's only B girl I can
tell you have jumped out of airplanes
before this I've done almost every sport
there is out there and done all these
thrills and have never felt the same as
I do when I'm dancing
I am a breakdancer and I go by the girls
snap one snap because I'm actually
double-jointed and then the one was
added because I'm still only be grow up
in a Alaska i strictly compete against
boys it makes you be good not for girl
but as a dancer professionally on the
uh-60 blackhawk mechanic i spend 40
hours a week
fixing helicopters inspecting
helicopters replacing major components
being in the army has taught me a lot of
self-discipline and focused because if
my body goes kaput I can't do my passion
[Music]
the hip-hop scene in Anchorage is very
small we are so far away from the rest
of the hip-hop scene in the United
States and in the world being able to
accomplish what our crew members have
been able to accomplish such a good
influence for everybody else that lives
here that if they just put enough time
and effort and passion into their craft
they can actually go somewhere and do
something with it
doing all these incredible things if my
body to the music and battering these
other people is a remarkable feeling
that I just simply can't get anywhere
else
when you head to the skate park you
expect to see skateboarders and BMX
riders but Aaron is bringing something a
little different kind of like a skater
has a skateboarder BMX player has a bike
I just saw the wheel should have
something fun so why not take it into
the park
[Music]
I'm Ehren wheels bothering him and I
ride WCMS WCM X stands for wheelchair
motocross it's you know taking your
chair into the skate park and hitting
ramp kind of the same thing as BMX but
with a wheelchair I first started going
to the skate parks when I was eight
years old and I've been doing it for 16
years now the wheelchair is definitely
just an extension of my body because
skaters aren't always on their
skateboard and bikers aren't always on
the bike but I'm always on my chair so
that gives me like an unfair advantage
to just practice everywhere I go I feel
like I'm lucky that I always have my
wheelchair with me because I can just
jump whenever I want I was born with
spina bifida I've had 21 surgeries
throughout my life and I spent a lot of
time in the hospitals and yeah it would
be easy to just be bummed out on that
but I was for me I just found the
positive the wheelchairs just always
been fun and it's wheels stuck to your
butt how's that not a great time
in 2008 I got the Guinness world record
for the first backflip on a wheelchair
now is that a local competition here in
Vegas cause I'm Jim that was a pretty
cool day one of my favorite tricks is
just simple handplant
because I always loved watching skaters
do it when I was growing up and you know
watching the pros do it it just was
something I wanted to learn I'm very
blessed to be able to do what I love and
what I'm passionate about for a living a
lot of the time the wheelchair comes
with the stereotype of you can't do this
or whatever because it's a medical
device
I just don't listen the wheelchair is a
great opportunity thanks for stopping by
a great big story quite the horse to
subscribe and put your comments down
below because we want to hear from you
and what you think we'll see you next
time bye